[Music]
text your questions your comments your
eggplant emojis to 937-202-4654
those texts literally go to ryan's of my
phones and eventually tk we'll get him
in on the action here as well we respond
to a lot of people just uh random
throughout the day but we also respond
to some folks
well here on the podcast looks like
lauren has a question for us how do you
handle birthday gifts you don't want
i've tried to make creative suggestions
but my family still wants to give me
physical gifts now jamie you'll recall
during the lightning round so we do our
best to answer questions with a short
shareable less than 140 characters why
are you playing that towards me because
i digress into a million different
tangents about trees every time i try to
answer a question
i'll try my best we call them minimal
maximums we put them in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media mine's like
thread one of 56.
here's my pithy answer let's unpack it
here a gift is not a gift if you are not
allowed to let it go
here's something else pithy for you a
relationship is not loving if it's not
honest so here's the thing how do you
approach someone you don't want gifts
from you just tell them you don't want
gifts because if you can't be honest
with someone that you love do you
actually love them are you in a real
relationship with someone if you can't
say hey i don't like that that's not a
relationship that's an obligation
if you feel afraid of the person in your
life you're afraid of rejection you're
afraid of not being accepted you're
afraid of not being loved that's not
love that's conditions right and so if
someone's giving you a gift why are they
giving you a gift it's because they want
to add value to your life and that's
wonderful so you can appreciate the gift
but once you get the gift know that it
is your gift to do whatever you want
with it you can donate it you can sell
it you can put it on your mantel you can
wear it you can choose to do nothing at
all with it that's totally fine a gift
is a gift but once it's your gift you do
whatever you want with it the reason
they're doing it is because they think
that gift giving is a love language well
that's nonsense that's like saying pig
latin is a romance language
we
give gifts because we want to add value
to someone's life it's not about the
gift it's about the adding value to your
life and if you're getting a gift and
it's extracting value from your life
it's getting in the way of your life
that's not what the gift giver intended
they want you to feel joyous from that
thing so instead of just saying no no no
no
say yes to something else here's the
type of gift that i would get value from
maybe it's just more time with you maybe
it's a gift card to applebee's whatever
it is probably not a gift card to
applebee's watching you slowly second
guess that uh in your head was so fun
you were like applebee's and then i just
watched you go what am i
gross hey man i met my wife at
applebee's
is that your that's true that's true
i love that
i was a teacher
[Laughter]
find a good woman at applebee's man
okay so
it's a variation of yours
the right to give it away is part of the
definition of a gift
if someone is truly giving you something
then part of what they have given you is
the right to do whatever you want with
that thing because it's now yours a gift
is a transferring of ownership right
they bought it they own what they paid
for and now they're transfer
transferring ownership to you i'll tell
you what you don't want to do and this
will get you in trouble you don't want
to get into the business of trying to
convert someone to your religious
beliefs about how they should spend
their money and what they should do with
gifts because that's the business of
trying to control people and it's only
going to lead to frustration people are
going to spend their money however they
want to spend it they're going to do
what they want to do with gifts however
they want to do it and if you try to
control them you're going to frustrate
them and yourself but here's what you
can do here's what's within the realm of
power for you you can reject it you can
receive it or you can redistribute it
you've got those three options and that
gives you all the power you need when
someone gives you a gift and you don't
like it
you can reject it and you can just be
honest and say nope i don't want it i
don't like physical gifts end of story
if you're not comfortable doing that no
problem you can you can do the second
thing you can receive it you can say
thank you kindly and then you can employ
the third option of redistributing it
let me find someone who would really
appreciate this and i'll give it to them
don't try to control them
and give yourself one of those three
options and you'll solve the problem
every time yeah my short answer is you
just go look at how sweet it is that
they tried right i
i have a kind of a weird trigger with
gifts and it was growing up as a kid and
getting
horrible last-minute gifts on christmas
from drunk family members and just i i
i'm weird with it and so every time i've
had you know an ex give me something i
said i didn't want or whatever it like
it it hits harder and i i don't like it
about me but
ever since i started kind of going like
oh this is cute even when it's a thing
so we have we have a a a family member
who gets us very weird gifts all me and
all my sub lanes every christmas and
it's and at first we were like what is
this like he has money what is he doing
and
now it has become our favorite thing
where we open it at the same time to be
like what bad [ __ ] crazy thing are we
all about to get and we laugh about it
and we don't even use it and sure it's a
waste but that moment of joy where we're
just all just dumbfounded around a
christmas tree is is is worth it so you
know you're gonna have that pang
of of of
hurt or whatever it is when you see the
gift you don't want and then you just
look at them and you go even if they
didn't listen you go yeah man it's just
it's sweet that they tried if it brought
that joy out of you though it turns out
that it's actually not a waste it's
brilliant right exactly that's beautiful
hey real quick just a little christmas
analogy santa claus has lots of gifts
that he doesn't want and that brings him
great joy because it's not about him
an unwanted gift is an opportunity to be
generous
and so many of us say i wish i could
help people more i wish i could share
more i wish i could give more and then
we get a gift that we don't want yeah we
don't recognize that moment for what it
is and we say oh my life is so terrible
but yeah that's the answer to that
prayer right there it's an opportunity
to be generous now you can bless someone
for free oh yeah my mom was a alcoholic
so we didn't leave milk and cookies for
sammy left uh beer and cookies
also funny story when i was very similar
when i was 16
i got a 16 16 16. i got a carton of
cigarettes uh for christmas and the best
part was it wasn't for my mom it was
from santa it was my stars in my
stocking uh and i couldn't have been
happier than marlboro menthol lights
cheers
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free